و نشير قبل ان نكمل بها الى هذا الخبر
الذي ياتي نقلا عن القناه الثاني عش
الاسرائيليه بسقوط قذيفه صاروخيه في منطقه
مفتوحه قرب مدينه
ستروت اذا نعود الان لقرار محكمه العدل
الدوليه في لاهاي هذا القرار الذي اطلق
سلسله من ردود الفعل ابرزها كان من الامين
العام للامم المتحده اذ قال المتحدث باسمه
ان ال ان الامين العام سيحيل الاخطار
بالتدابير المؤقته التي طالبت بها محكمه
العدل الدوليه الى مجلس الامن الدولي
فورا يشير الامين العام الى ان قرارات
المحكمه بموجب ميثاق الامم المتحده
والنظام الاساسي للمحكمه ملزمه ويثق في ان
جميع الاطراف سوف يمتثلون على النحو
الواجب لامر المحكمه ووفقا للنظام الاساسي
للمحكمه سيحيل الامين العام على الفور
الاختار بالتدابير المؤقته التي امرت فيها
المحكمه الى مجلس الامن الدولي